Shania Twain told our very own Roz
Weston that you'd caught the acting bug
so naturally we're invited down to
Birmingham Alabama to sit down with the
Grammy award-winning actress as cameras
were rolling on her first ever feature
film trading paint be marker Shanna is
born to be on film her videos say that
the videos are knockout but I think this
is such a beautiful role well it's fun
and it feels really natural for me like
it's just an environment that I'm not
was gonna be really intimidated have you
been nervous at all
I was unexpectedly or just like a
surprisingly comfortable and I know that
I was a lot to do with John this is my
son think you are smoking hot think I'm
cool
yeah starting off your film career with
John Travolta a two-time Oscar nominee
an Emmy nominee and a Golden Globe
winner it's a pretty smart move so when
the trading paint opportunity came up
for Shania to play John's veteran car
race and girlfriend and learned from one
of the best it was an easy yes I would
have never cut classes it's not good
with the problem student oh I bet you
are
and I want to had you sort it out in no
time just watching him in the moment so
I'm really amazed what about singing on
the Spivey's admit it he's singing on
the spot yeah I mean I didn't reveal our
little secret about the song that we
were thinking about okay but I told I
told him that it I was looking at you
and the only hint obvious she looked so
magnificently gorgeously beautiful that
I just this song came right into my head
and I started to sing it this is between
takes no I'm Karen and yes I said I love
that song she said that'd be a good duet
I wanted to do a duet album with him
years ago Wow
we needed that needs to come to life
music is a big part of my life and I
miss I miss doing it so I will fill it
and of course I want to create an effect
on others I will break out into a
familiar and then that that's kind of
funny there's for instance think all the
you've seen every scene shots of these
cars yeah of course yeah where they were
all lined up and there's a bunch of guys
and girls around the cars and I'm in
front of them I thought if I broke into
greased lightning right now I bet it
would cause a very good effect
so I Google really
[Music]
well the whole crew everyone went crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
do you have a favorite Shania Twain son
if you had to pick them there's so many
but if you had to pick one okay so you
got a car that don't impress me much
certainly that that is an icon of a song
but I have too many I like you know I I
could listen to Shania all day the cars
look cool they look amazing out there
and I know in a past interview with
Entertainment Tonight Canada you had
said you were talking about your son
you're like I just want to be a cool mom
again and I want to be a cool mom have
you let it be known that you want to act
I've have so has anybody know anything
yet a script for anything a treatment no
I'm saying it now for the first time I'm
guessing this has got you a ton of cool
points oh no kidding with all the guys
in family oh yeah wait oh yeah wait til
up we all get together I mean the cars
I'm one of the guys you know hanging
around the motor